This video is brought to you by Henson Shaving.
Tesla has fascinated the world with
its cool and fast electric cars.
Now it wants to disrupt a
related industry: insurance.
Tesla has been quietly selling car
insurance for the last couple of years.
But it won’t be quiet for much longer.
CEO Elon Musk believes insurance will one
day account for a third of Tesla’s business.
It will be much more compelling
than anything else out there.
It’s gonna cost less and be
better, so, why wouldn’t you?
Tesla started selling personal car
insurance in California in 2019
and claims drivers can trim their insurance
costs by as much as 20% or 30%.
Data compiled by the personal financial
website ValuePenguin shows Tesla Insurance
is not the cheapest in California but
it is amongst the least expensive.
It is said to be the least costly plan
in Texas where Tesla has a lot going on.
A new Gigafactory is being built
near Austin. And Musk permanently
moved to the Lonestar state to be closer
to SpaceX’s rocket facility for Starship.
State regulators there have reportedly approved
the rates and policies for Tesla Insurance
which, according to data compiled by
ValuePenguin, is $1,795 on average.
Individual rates do differ greatly
depending on your driving record,
age, how much coverage you
choose, and the Tesla you buy.
The Model Y mid-size SUV is
the least expensive to insure.
And if you take the Model S, rates
could be more expensive for the Plaid,
which goes 0 to 100 in 2.1 seconds compared
with the long-range version’s 3.2 seconds.
So, why can Tesla afford to
offer lower insurance rates?
It says it will do away with fees taken
by traditional insurance carriers.
An example of fees is commissions
paid to insurance brokers.
And more importantly - Tesla argues no
one knows more about a Tesla than Tesla.
While other insurance companies
set their insurance rates based on
their own risk assessments, which could be
inflated because the technology is so new,
Tesla believes only it knows the cars
well enough to determine fair rates.
The insane amount of data collected
from its cars tracks how fast you drive,
the number of times the lane
departure warning is triggered,
whether you’re in ludicrous mode
or the even faster plaid mode.
Although Tesla says it does share driving data
with other insurers - the belief is that it
“...uniquely understands its vehicles,
technology, safety, and repair costs.”
For the moment, Tesla says it doesn’t use your
personal driving data to determine insurance rates
but that will almost certainly change
in the future. Musk has hinted at this.
If they want to buy Tesla insurance,
they have to agree to not drive the car
in a crazy way. Or, they can, but
then the insurance rates higher.
Toyota has already been testing this
out. It partnered with insurance
company Progressive to start
tracking driving behaviors in
Toyotas with connected technology
to potentially offer discounts.
There’s a lot of room for discounting
when it comes to electric vehicles.
The typical insurance company has
been found to price EVs at 23%
more than a gas-powered equivalent primarily
due to the expensive cost of repairing them.
A few years ago, a writer for CleanTechnica
described clipping a parking sign in his Model 3
and the repair bill was nearly a whopping $7,000.
A big chunk of that was labor costs
because of the technology in the car:
the sensors needed to be recalibrated
and the battery connectors disconnected.
Tesla thinks it has an advantage
here as well. The company says its
own service centers can work four
times faster than conventional ones.
The number of Tesla repair centers
has been rapidly expanding.
And the goal is to reportedly open up
one new shop every week in 2021.
But ultimately, Tesla wants to make its vehicles
so reliable that you won’t really
need to visit a service center.
Tesla believes its self-driving
software called Full Self-Driving
or FSD will make its cars safer
and less prone to accidents.
This is the software that Tesla
hopes will take its cars from
Level 2 autonomy in which the driver
has to be prepared to take the wheel
all the way up to Level 5 in which the driver
doesn’t have to pay any attention at all.
Tesla will even offer insurance discounts for
those using their driver assistance systems.
If and when Teslas are able
to fully drive themselves,
it doesn’t mean accidents won’t happen. Technology
can fail or humans can fail to use it properly.
So how on earth will other
insurance companies assess the risk?
It will be easier over time as more
data comes in that will better inform
companies about pricing risk in line with reality.
But they may have a hard time catching up to
Tesla, which is now seeking to offer coverage
in Texas, Illinois, and Washington. The goal is
nationwide coverage, and one day, perhaps, global.
It’s clear that Tesla wants to offer
a complete package to the consumer.
Apple has done this successfully by creating
an ecosystem where its devices are designed
to work seamlessly with one another
which entices you to buy them all.
Tesla is now trying to build its own ecosystem in
which your house has a Tesla solar roof that
generates energy that can be stored in a Tesla
powerwall which can power your home at night or
during an outage. The powerwall can also charge
your Tesla, then you can purchase Autopilot and
full self-driving software for your car, and your
car is conveniently covered by Tesla Insurance.
But not everyone is a fan of the insurance plan.
Berkshire Hathaway CEO Warren Buffett said
bluntly at an annual shareholders meeting that:
“The success of the auto companies getting
into the insurance business is probably
as likely as the success of the insurance
companies getting into the auto business.”
Buffett became one of the wealthiest people
on earth by investing in insurance companies.
Despite his skepticism, Musk has proven
his doubters wrong time and time again.
He believes Tesla Insurance
will be stunningly successful.
Insurance could very well be, I don’t know, 30%,
40% of the value of the car business, frankly.
If Tesla reaches its goal of producing 20 million
cars a year by 2030, and you multiply that by
$1,795 in annual insurance
premiums - that brings in $36 billion a year.
That’s $36 billion year after year after year!
And owners of a robotaxi - the planned
ride sharing network - would likely pay
higher premiums due to the many more
hours the vehicles are on the road.
In the way that Tesla has been
revolutionizing the car industry,
Musk is betting it can do the same
to the car insurance business.
There’s also another company revolutionizing
an industry: the shaving industry!
When Henson Shaving reached out about trying
their razor and possibly sponsoring a video,
I didn't actually know a lot about them.
I've now learned that they build their razors with
the help of their family-owned Canadian
aerospace manufacturer that built parts
for the Mars rover to ensure that their
razor meets extremely tight tolerances.
That precision really gives a smoother
shave. This razor has very little
blade exposure - less than 30 microns. And
it's easy to use - there's no learning
period like with other safety razors because
the shaving angle is built into the head design.
Now that I've tried out a Henson, I
won't be using disposable razors anymore.
Although this razor costs more than
disposable ones, you make your money
back because it lasts a lifetime. And get
this - the cost of a blade is only 10 cents.
If you change your blade every week then
you’ll pay just $5 for an entire year’s supply.
The razor comes in eight colors
and ships all around the world.
If you’d like to try out a Henson
razor - or gift one to your family or a
friend - then you can use the link in my description.
Thanks so much for watching. For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.